the fairy tale childhood is lasting too
long and then they're falling from a
cliff with disappointment it's a big
issue these young people didn't get born
this way they've been made this way they
have they um get shuttled off to a
therapist and it all gets
professionalized and pathologized and
weirded out who am I will lead to well
you might be trans I know that sounds a
leap but if people Google it as if
you're a teenager you'll see the jumps
go quite
fast Stella m welcome to trigonometry
thanks for having me it's a real
pleasure having you on the show uh we're
going to talk all about teens and mental
health and all of that interesting stuff
and of course the trans issue which you
can never get away from these days
before we do tell everybody a little bit
about who are you how are you where you
are what has been the journey through
life that leads you to be sitting here
talking to us well uh as you said I'm a
psychotherapist and I'm based in Ireland
and up until I come came late to
psychotherapy I didn't kind of qualify
until I was about 30 and then up until
about the last five years I was very
general and I wrote you know books and
articles in the National media in
Ireland about mental health so mental
health is my thing and um I've I I'm
particularly interested in teenagers and
young people because when I had my kids
which was 2007 and 2009 I kind of
realized what a shocked that it was
incredibly unhealthy their Lifestyles as
such that was being shown just you know
the general presuming of how we should
raise our kids was very intensive and
almost like battery chickens if you
follow me and that's when I got really
really into um the kind of mental health
of children and and then you know when
you're good at something it more of it
comes to you I started seeing way more
teenagers and then I became in and data
with teenagers so more and more of kind
of I had a hard life as a teenager so
that's where my sympathy that's where my
heart life is really and doing the
calculations you've got two teenagers
now as well I do I do they're having an
easy time so
far they'll tell me they're having a
hard time with they're all right yeah uh
and uh obviously there's a lot going on
with teenagers nowadays yeah it seems to
be that they have challenges that we
didn't have when we were kids they do
they do in lots of ways you know when
when I was a teenager and when you were
teenagers in a way we kind of we just
about left repression we were just
starting to kind of find our way I know
some people say oh no we were repressed
and stuff we were kind of pulling out of
it it might have been quite difficult to
be gay it might have been certainly
difficult as a as a girl to find your
you know sexual place you know what I
mean it wasn't particularly easy but
where they are now is just horrendously
diff it's no comparison there's no doubt
it's a lot worse and I thought like up
until really
up until the end of the 20th century
arguably you know life was getting
better and better and better but
mentally it's like we've regressed in
quite a significant way in the last 20
years or so and that is absolutely borne
out by all the evidence I mean the
research shows it very clearly people's
I mean it's subjective so we don't know
whether it's genuinely happening I
suppose or whether it's people feeling
worse in you know they think they're
feeling worse but they can't you know we
can't compare but the the studies do
show that
right why do you think that
is it's it's very subjective because if
a kid thinks they're really depressed
and I meet them and they tell me how
anxious they are and how depressed they
are and you look at them and you think
yeah I know you think you are but
actually if we look at the actual facts
of your life they're not that bad
certainly compared to your own mother
who might have had you know what I mean
quite difficulty so then you think is
pain worse just because I know right cuz
I think of like my grandparents like my
grandmother lived through stalinism gags
German Nazi occupation I don't remember
her ever talking about depression do you
know what I mean of of being an
adolescent yeah yeah yeah it's it's a
real I we can't compare any of the
previous studies because there's there's
such a heightened emphasis on Mental
Health these days and there's so much
kind of are you okay are you depressed
you know like kids coming in and they
kind of say I think depressed and I
think it's clinical and they have all
this language and I'm like going I think
you are very distressed and I think you
are very in plugged into the mental
health industry which has sold you
frankly a line that it could be serious
and you might need serious attention as
if there's a Man Behind the Green
curtain who'll come out with some sort
of magic Elixir that will kind of make
them better rather than actually The
Human Condition is quite difficult being
a a human once you get into adolescence
and you complexify your brain you
realize actually life is really
difficult and they haven't often figured
that bit out they think I'm finding life
really difficult so actually to go back
to your question I do think they're lost
and being lost is a particularly
horrible place to be and they're
incredibly uncertain of everything they
can't even depend on the news Remember
You The News was the news and maybe not
for yourself in Russia but like
but used to be that the news was the
news you knew where you stood like yeah
it was the odd Scandal but really you
knew what was what was solid there isn't
a solidity they can't everything is fake
news I don't know I don't believe that I
reject those facts so they have this
uncertain really really really kind of
clay that they're standing on and it's
making them feel incredibly uncertain
and all the markets the economic markets
will say bad news is fine good news is
great uncertainty is what what really
Wallops the mind that's what we can't
actually cope with and that's what the
adolescence are living in a very
uncertain world where they can't trust
anything isn't part of the problem as
well is that adolescence is crap it's
always been crap it's always been
terrible it's always been really really
unpleasant
and you hear kids talk about all of
these things and there's a part of me
that goes yeah that's just being a
teenager yeah I don't know because
sometimes I go yeah yeah right okay ad
my adolescence was crap I part of me
thinks we we you know we arrived on the
teenager in the 1950s yeah we did and
when we did we sexualized girls and a
very high speed and like the songs from
the 50s and 60s they're saying some
really crazy things about little girl
and oh yeah there's there's a very
famous song by Gary Pucket in the
something Union called young girl get
out of my mind I know that's so yeah
yeah and it's I mean it's a brilliant
song then you listen to the lyrics BBC
classic yeah exactly and it's but you
know and it's you go well this is you
know this is disgusting sweet little 16
by Chuck Barry yeah there's so many of
them like Rolland stones and stuff there
some really really extraordinary and
this happens in the 50s Well yeah if you
think about it James Dean the teenager
arrived and it was very cool it was very
Americanized was very consumer culture
but it was still very attractive but
arguably the sexualization of the
teenage girl has happened since then and
arguably since then maybe since then I I
don't have data to back it up we weren't
checking out the mental health of
teenagers in the 30s or the 20s but
there's a there's a there's a question
to be asked about the sexualization of
girls because anorexia arrived in the
70s and then bulimia in the 80s then we
got self harm we've got gender do you
know what I mean you can see these are
girls who hate their bodies and you
can't help but think well teenage girl
as a thing hasn't gone very well has
it so the concept of teenagehood is what
you're actually talking about like more
and more I'm thinking because everybody
says adolesence is awful and I'm like
yeah we don't actually know what what
was it like to be I don't know a
15-year-old in any other era we because
there was no such thing as a teenager so
they kind of they grew up and then they
worked do you know what I mean there
wasn't that period the the actual
concept of the teenager was created in
about 1911 by Stanley Halla psychologist
like that this is a thing this is the
time of Storms and stresses and then it
built on and then you know the pop
culture created it in a big way with the
50s it's just not gone well is all I can
think and then you factor in social
media on top of that and that has just
made it infinitely worse it's so
sophisticated and it's happening so
young and it's so horrible to see this
kind of hypers sexualization of kids
I've so many kids and this is pre-teen
this is when they're 10 and 11 and it's
happening all the time it's
extraordinary how often that one kid in
the class gets a phone one kid in the
class is hypersexualized Maybe by their
older brother or their older there
always was one or two kids but they come
in with their phones and they take
photos and some kid is taking their top
off or their bottoms off and there's
photos taken and they are so out of
their depth they are so not able for
they're so they're babies still they're
usually prepubescent do you know what I
mean and they they've got this kind of
device that's just way Beyond them that
we've allowed to happen it'll be like
the smoking do you remember when you
know in the 1950s and when I was a kid
like you could buy single cigarettes
around the corner because they knew all
the children were smoking so you you
didn't have to buy 10 do you feel me
that's how common it was to smoke it'll
be the same I think with the phones that
will go wow look at love look at the way
they had those phones for the kids and
why is it not more of a scandal because
we're seeing you know the effects that
Instagram in particular is having on
young girls let's can we talk about that
a little bit because to me that is is
horrendous it's horrible and they become
really vain because Society has taught
them to be do you know what I mean it's
not that they grew they kind of woke up
as vain they be they were created Vain
and they become incredibly judgmental of
everybody else's looks their own looks
and they're obsessed with their look
whether it's not only just vanity of of
but like they know about their whether
their lips are nice or their nose is
nice or their eyes are nice when they're
10 like you know what I mean their their
self-consciousness arrives much earlier
now because of all the photos but people
you know In fairness parents are taking
photos of their kids at a very young age
so this photo photo photo photo photo
and then they have this pose by the time
they're five the kids have this pose
they know how to pose and then by the
time they're you know in their pre-teens
they're on Instagram and it's it's just
vanity r large and what what effect does
that have on things like eating disorder
self-perception body dysmorphia Etc it's
a direct line it's a direct line between
if you're constantly looking at yourself
and you know putting filters in of
yourself and then kind of trying to
improve your pose at all times and then
you're comparing yourself
with others I remember Time Magazine did
a a a study of the different platforms
and they were kind of astonished to find
out that Instagram was the one that made
people feel worse the one that's
supposed to be which is classic of this
world what you think is never what you
think you know what I mean the one
that's supposed to make you feel good is
the one that actually wrecks your head
but with girls what it what it moves
very quickly from vanity
to kind of a very critical analysis of
what's wrong with them and they
generally hate various aspects of them I
remember one girl who came in to me and
she we had a lovely relationship and I
took a while you know what I mean and
I'll change the details of this but
effectively then after a while she said
well you know you know my eye and I
says what about your eye just like my
eye as if there was this massive thing I
couldn't even tell which eye she meant
do you know what I mean and basically
from looking at if you look at the miror
for hours upon hours I figured it out
during Zoom I i' never looked in my face
so much during the co era you know what
I mean all those zooms I suddenly oh my
all those things wrong with my face but
this girl had decided that there was
something wrong with her eye it was so
minor you couldn't see it visibly from
to just looking at herself all that I'm
looking at herself critically but it it
turns it sounds silly and it is in a way
but it ends up not silly when you got
gripped into either anorexia or a body
dysmorphia which is an Obsession about
one part of your face maybe your or your
body your nose or your breast or your
eye or whatever and the grip of mental
illness then it's not funny then it's a
it's a hell it's a prison it's it's
really awful so when you tip in just
because you've tipped in because of a
vacuous culture that was all around
vanity doesn't mean that when you've
gone in it isn't
extraordinarily powerful it's
devastating oh absolutely and it feeds a
narcissism as well I remember my wife
and I were on holiday day in Spain and
we went to uh a castle and there was a
girl there taking a selfie of herself
and I I just caught out the corner of my
eye she she was staring into her phone
ready ready to take the selfie and it
looked like she looked like she was in
love do you know what I mean I do she
had this this like being in love fa and
I remember just thinking whoa that is
quite a weird emotion to be experiencing
when you're taking a photo of yourself
you're yeah yeah you know and and and I
think the one thing that doesn't get
said enough that I'm so glad you said is
these young people didn't get born this
way they've been made this way they have
yeah you know what I mean and when you
chat with them on a deep level which I
would be doing you wouldn't um you would
think a COR you know that they know it's
all crap they know it's all Vain and
vacuous they have deeper impulses but
nothing about social media Instagram
nothing about Society Has Lifted the
better part of themselves and everything
about Society is feeding into the base
more basic parts but just to say about
the beaming in when I went to see the
Eiffel Tower with my kids last year it
was unbelievable all around the Eiffel
Tower everybody was taking selfies with
this Eiffel Tower in the backg no
everybody had their back to the
Eiffel taking photos it was like oh my
God what is happening nobody's looking
at at the Eiffel Tower and everybody was
looking at it with their back and it was
it was horrible to watch it was like
we've really lost it we've really lost
it because it's also encouraging people
especially women to focus on their looks
but what happens as you get older and
your looks start to fade as will happen
with all of us yeah I know and it's it's
it has been researched that the better
looking women find it harder to get
older and I can see why you know what I
mean well you're losing more yeah you
you yeah and it's not only that you so
many doors opened for you so many I
remember I was in a I was with somebody
and she had been gorgeous and she asked
the waiter to do something for her and
he said sorry like no and she's like oh
and she's like I used to be gorgeous she
said to me like she used to be able to
get anything like that like an awful lot
of doors slamming your face when you're
not as pretty anymore but I think I have
to say one thing I've noticed like when
let's say I was growing up in the 80s
and ' 90s and the boys were joyfully
unselfconscious in many way there was
the odd there's always going to be
extremes there was the OD but mostly
they weren't that bothered about their
looks and the girls were very
preoccupied but rather than the girls
following the boys the boys have
followed the girl boys have become much
more vain they're much more into bulking
up and bulking is a huge part of you
know Eating Disorders you know the girls
are getting skinnier and the boys are
bulking up and it's an issue it it
shouldn't be underestimated because it's
they're really becoming very bothered
about their looks the boys and what and
and why is that social media as well or
is that or are there other factors
involved yeah that's massively to do
with social media and the looks and
frankly there's been a huge amount of um
uh targeted consumerism you know what I
mean there's an awful lot of sales going
to the boys to up their game and it's
working I think it's it's it's just
we've become such a brand oriented
society that we all look much better if
any of us were from 40 years ago none of
us would look as good as we do know yeah
it's we all look better but we're
putting in a lot more effort we do we
yeah I I don't know I don't I really
don't bother too much but you know it's
interesting I've noticed this trend as
well I actually wrote a piece about on
my substack about Jordan pet why they
hate Jordan Peterson and one of the
observations I made in it I think as
we've got to Society where we've tried
to suppress healthy masculinity or
perhaps in the desire to deal with
unhealthy masculinity we've also
suppress healthy masculinity because
we've tied everybody with the same brush
looking bulky is one of the few socially
acceptable ways of like being a man now
I would do you know what I mean or do I
agree with you no I agree with you I
think there isn't much of a place for
there isn't
many decent role models for men for
young boys for boys to you know to to
Aspire to and I think they they're
they're kind of they're veering wildly
from Andrew Tate to kind of Jordan
Peterson and you know various other
people and some of these people are
great and I'm well aware of it but I
think the boys don't have a firm idea of
where they're
going and I think it's difficult to
contend with and I know the girls have
their own challenges and I'm not
underestimating it at all but I do think
there's something about being a boy that
they don't quite know what for example
this is a big one for boys these days
and I've really noticed it so when
testosterone comes in you know they they
have very strong sexual urges right and
it doesn't come in like the way it seems
to come in for boys it comes in much
more well for me anyway and for most
girls it seems to go much more gradually
but it seems to hit boys over the head
and they suddenly kind of go sex mad
quite quickly so they're quite sweet
boys and then they turn
into yeah yeah they do and um they're
they're kind of ashamed of it now you
know what I mean and I I remember um uh
my for example my my uh daughter was
talking about her friend and the her
friend friend's best friend is a boy so
it's a girl and a boy and they're best
friends and the boy is staying over in
our house in the same bed and they're 15
and I said well that's insane and
everybody all the teams that were around
me were like he's not a creep he's not
going to just suddenly lunge at her and
I was like well no I I wasn't saying
he's a creep but I was thinking of this
poor guy feeling like he's a creep if he
wants to Lunge at her but he's a
15-year-old boy in bed with another
15-year-old girl it's mad but it felt to
me like the kind of weird double speak
that happens these days that yeah he's a
creep if he kind of has his very normal
natural impulse in the middle of the
night with a 15-year-old girl very
pretty 15-year-old girl beside I just
thought everything about that was wrong
and it says a lot that story there so
much of this going on society where we
want to pretend reality isn't what it is
and then all of the Cascades down
from that yeah which is what you talking
about there which is if you pretend boys
don't have the sexual urge at 15 and if
they do their creeps then everything
else follows you're supposed to be able
to sleep in a bed with a girl that
you're not yeah but 15 regularly no no
no no no no you know what I mean now we
know this cuz we're old world almost do
you know what I mean because they were
there was a group of them that were
stunned and their big emphasis was he's
not a creep why would you think that and
I'm like but he's a 15-year-old boy I'd
never met the boy it's just that's not a
healthy scenario that you would
regularly expose a 15-year-old boy to
and I'm not you know like we can all see
what you it could be implied by what I'm
saying I'm not saying any of that I'm
just saying you've got to to respect the
fact that there's an influx of hormones
that is very intense for boys and they
don't quite know what to do with it now
and honestly they're shaming themselves
like bold don't think that and they I've
no doubt because I meet these boys it
goes weird if you keep on telling all
your sexual impulses are kind of toxic
and creepy do you follow me it's not
going to end very well it's basically
shaming boys for their sexual impulses
and then you factor in hardcore pornog
graphy which they all have access to
yeah and I was just imagin this poor boy
and God knows him I don't know okay but
I was just imagine him being shamed in
the bed and then lashing out to the
toilet for some hardcore porn coming
back and I was just thinking this is
he's not a creep though so all right
yeah and then you're factoring the
Catholic Church on top oh dear oh dear
so I I suppose the question first of all
is um you know there will be a lot of
parents who who have teenagers as you do
yeah um what what can parents do before
we get to the advice for kids and stuff
like that what can parents do about this
we'll be back with our guest in a minute
but first do you remember the Canadian
trucker protest in 2022 where thousands
of Canadians came out to protest covid
restrictions and vaccine mandates now
these protests lasted for weeks and the
people out on the streets needed funds
as any Grassroots protest would so
people set up online crowdfunding
campaigns which rais millions of dollars
incredible but once the Canadian
authorities had started to criticize a
crowdfunding platforms ramping up
pressure to close the campaigns it
didn't take long for the biggest
crowdfunding platform the one we've all
heard of to completely capitulate and
shut the campaigns down now this is
where our partners give send go come in
they stepped in when the other platforms
backed off and raised millions of
dollars for the truckers when they were
criticized and dragged through the
Canadian courts GF and go said it
respected diverse views and believed
hope and freedom are values worth
fighting for this is why we're proud to
partner with GI and go so if you need to
crowdfund for whatever means the most to
you then don't go to the big Tech
platforms we recommend you do it on give
send go starting a campaign on give send
go is easy and intuitive go to giv send
go.com today that's giv send go.com to
to start raising money for whatever is
important to you and now back to the
interview yeah well the reason I wrote
my book I'm a therapist I'm a
psychotherapist I kind of believe in
Psychotherapy um less and less every
year but I still do believe in it and um
thankfully I I seem to be good at my
work and I seem to I've seen huge kind
of differences from working with
teenagers so that's been lovely however
my my my reason for writing the book was
to kind of encourage parents to take
control of their own families and not to
immediately triangulate by bringing in
the experts by bringing in a
psychotherapist by bringing in a CBT
because actually in my experience it
hasn't gone very well that we've kind of
got this lightweight pseudo mental
health industry that is making everybody
kind of think that that they need
therapy and it's not going well for
these teenagers so the teenager might be
as you said all adolescent it's quite a
hard place to be they're a bit dis
distressed in the middle of depressed
and they um get shuttled off to a
therapist and it all gets
professionalized and pathologized and
weirded out and the kids thinks they're
specially upset and it's suddenly turned
into this Crown kind of major event as
opposed to you're just suffering from
The Human Condition you've complexified
your brain and you've realized life is
deeply unfair and Incredibly un
unsatisfactory in many ways and and
that's something you're going to have to
get your head around maybe with art or
literature music or film there lots of
ways to get
around charging off to the therapist is
sending a very wrong message to young
people that they can be fixed and that
there's this kind of golden world out
there where there's golden people and
golden friendships and you know you get
out of bed and you feel good and you
feel good all the way through the day
and you never have moments of Despair
and anxiety that's what we're selling
them by by sending them to the therapist
too early they think you know what I
mean it's their first juncture of oh my
God life is
hard and they say oh you think life is
hard okay well you know let's get you to
the therapist it's a real huge issue so
it's kind of a book to say don't send
them to the therapist read the book
equip yourself just if they've got a
little bit of anxiety you know learn a
bit about of anxiety if they're starting
to kind of towards disordered eating
learn a bit about it read up a bit bit
about it and handle your own child you
know to equip yourself so you can handle
your own child because it's very
disempowering for a parent to bring and
it triangulates the situation and a
triangulation in any situation would
make let's say for example the child
would be the um the victim the the
parent would be the persecutor and the
therapist is the savior and
triangulation happens all the time in
different like it happens with divorces
you know the father is the persecutor
the mother is the savior the child is
the victim it's always bad so bringing
in this savior person to fix the child
is such a dangerous thing I'm not saying
never sometimes there's real deep trauma
and distress and we need professional
help a lot of the time I
think the person can handle it they can
handle it in lots of different ways one
thing I've really noticed which I think
is kind of important to note is that an
awful lot of childhood these days is is
gorgeous actually it's kind of like they
you know they fabulous activities
amazing birthday parties they've got
Christmas which is just magical they've
even got all sorts of new kind of type
Christmases like tooth fairies and
Easter bunnies and Halloweens and it's
unbelievably magical and it's we as
parents CU we're we're grim and jaded we
kind of get into it in in an extremity
that's never happened before so you have
a lot of people for example live
believing in Santa until really quite an
old age I remember I say it in my book
there was my my beauty therapist she was
doing my nails or something I don't
usually get things like that don't what
she did and the first time she got drunk
was when she learned about Santa she
didn't do you follow me so she was 13
and she still believed in Santa and she
was with her mates and they were all
getting drunk and she said what are you
getting for Santa and they
said there's no Santa and everybody
laughed at her and she was drunk and she
cried all the way home drunk and crying
went into her mommy's arm
13 you you wait you say you're kid will
grow up and you'll think when is he
going to my K you remember I'm Russian
he's getting a hard dose of reality at
about three you say that wait you see cu
the whole school would say why have you
wrecked it why have you wrecked it on
every yeah so it's a massive conspiracy
she was 13 yeah this only few years ago
The Great Santa conspiracy I taught an
11-year-old who believed in Santa and I
told him at the age of 11 Santa doesn't
exist well done son yeah and then his
mom had to go at me and I went your kid
is about to go to comprehensive School
in East London it's better that he hears
it from me than he goes to a
comprehensive in East London and
announces to to demand him that he
believes in Santa gets his head kicked
in you you you would be surprised how
many of them now believe in Santa 11 12
13 you would be surprised loads of kids
are leaving in Center until an old age
like I say she was getting drunk and it
was just such a crazy combination of and
it's what I think is really important
which is this kind of magical childhood
where all everything is just gorgeous
it's all kind of you know Sparkles and
Easter bunnies and stuff and fairies and
then they hit adolescence and very
quickly it becomes grim and hard and
life is difficult and actually your
friends don't really like what you like
you and they're quite competitive and
they're slagging you off and you know
homelessness we have no solution for
that and racism we have no solution for
that and you know it's just it's so Grim
so fast that they fall from a cliff from
disappointment so I see a lot of kids in
and around 12 or so they've just gone to
their first year of secondary and they
come in like they walked into a wall and
generally after a little bit of time I
say something along the lines of are you
a bit disappointed in life and they're
like yeah it's awful it's nothing like
what I thought it was going to be like
childhood was lovely and then it's just
bang really hard very quickly and I
think the the massive change has never
happened before because when we were
kids there was a Dawning at a much
earlier age that all of this that life
was actually harder it was much slower
Dawning and it crept up on you while the
the kind of the the the fairy tale
childhood is lasting too long and then
they're falling from a cliff with
disappointment it's a big issue that's a
really interesting point we had a guy
called Mark walon who who's a trauma
expert he worked with trauma and one of
the things he was talking about is the
lack of initiation rituals that we would
have had in the past and when that you
know in in more Prim I mean we say
primitive and then technologically
they're more primitive whether they're
culturally more primitive is another
conversation but um they would have for
for boys for example you're a boy and
you you you know you stay with the women
for a while and you're not really part
of the male society and then when you
hit puberty it's like you go out and you
kill a whatever and then you wear it
horns on your neck or whatever it might
be and from this point on you get
treated like a man and that means
different things are expected of you and
this like you know comfortable world
that you live in you are now rewarded by
being initiated into the male world to
which actually all boys Aspire actually
right um but we don't have that anymore
no what happens when you're 13
or 12 or whatever it is nobody initiates
you into a different world and I imagine
there would have been a similar thing
for women where there is obviously a
natural transition from girlhood to to
adolescence to sexual maturity again
there's a transition I don't know how
many whether as many girls immediately
aspired to that right at the beginning
but my point is we don't have a way of
in you know a path for people to follow
yeah I couldn't agree more and we need
to bring them back those ceremonial
rights of Passage they were with us for
millions of years and suddenly we've
done away with them and I do think it
makes people again that uneasiness the
uncertainty of young people they they
don't have anything to kind of grab on
to as in I have done this WR of Passage
and I am now in the next stage they
don't have any of that and they feel it
like little boys look at men and they
can't imagine being a man it's just so
hard for a little boy to imagine being a
man you need these stages and then don't
worry you're part of a process your
daddy did it before you and your
granddad did it before you that's been
taken away nothing's been replaced and
as a result you've got people who are
just very anxious it's no wonder that's
what they are cuz there's nothing that
can rely on there's no certainty there's
no solidity and as a man what can I'm
something I'm thinking about what can
you do with your son to to to to offset
that as much as you can I think if at
all possible I think it's important and
that's where I'm really into like
parents kind of going for it and saying
well what can I do well you can bring in
a kind of a very definitive knowledge of
your ancestors easily done you know what
I mean you look it up but so that they
know where they came from and they know
that there was different walks of life
in their families and secondly you can
bring in rights of Passage I don't know
what it would be but you look through
your culture and you you figure out what
you should bring back just because
Society has got rid of it doesn't mean
that you should allow it to be got rid
of for your kids because I I think would
make a huge difference so that they
realize they're part of the circle as
opposed to they're just cast into this
21st century digital age and this is why
religion actually is so valuable in many
ways because I was raised Catholic you
had your first communion you you you
were baptized then you had your first
communion then you were confirmed and so
on and so so forth with Judaism B
Mitzvah that's really important to have
these rituals so that people understand
where they are when it comes to the
circle of life it's really interesting
like this now we're I think we're in the
post-religious age I know other people
would say we're not and there's all
sorts of kind of upsurge in religion but
the kids I see the normal Western kids I
see just God and religious nothing to do
with them and there's I I'm a Catholic
as well so went through all those
ceremonies and my kids aren't my kids
are Protestant and I I thought my
husband was going to give them all these
cermonies he was useless at it you can't
trust the Protestants we we've known
that for a while right let's not start
the troubles right here on the show
thank you very much I should have
know um yeah but we we did bring in some
kind of um
ceremonial events to follow me and I
remember thinking this is going to make
weirdos of us if we don't watch
ourselves in the town you know what I
mean because it's so unusual if you
follow me to do stuff like that so that
that was a bit of a shock but when you
look at some of the anxiety that's
manifesting you really start thinking
about the post-religious age because OCD
is very is a very good example OCD is
often very much about um repetitive
gestures and there's a lot of kind of um
what would you call them symmetrical
gestures with OCD and when you look at a
lot of religious ceremonies like
blessing yourself and the rosary beads
and all those kind of they were like for
the anxious people who were inclined
towards looking for a framework the
feeling that God's in his heaven and if
I do you know seven decades of the
Rosary I'll be okay it was so calming
for anybody that there was somebody
looking after them and they didn't need
to think all that much because there was
actually something going on that they
didn't understand and all of those
people have been plugged out of that
framework we took it away from them and
they have nothing and where are they
going they're going into anxiety and OCD
I remember reading this extraordinary
kind of account of this this boy who who
just kept on blessing himself even
though he'd never had anything religious
and I thought yeah that's that makes
sense to me now that we've left religion
that it feels it's not accidental for
thousands of years they had all these
symmetrical gestures that cammed people
and then we took them away and they're
coming in in different ways and we and
you no longer worship God but that
doesn't mean you're going to stop
worshiping something or someone which
again is when the social media thing
comes back into it when you worship
celebrity you worship follow accounts
you worship all of these things yeah the
social media aspect I think we're still
in the baby pool we don't know I don't
think anybody's in any doubt it's been
devastating it's been fabulous for
people who are older but I think it's
been devastating for young people and
yeah you're right the human disposition
is
towards idolizing people idolizing Gods
looking towards other people who have it
sust just give me anybody and if it's if
the culture is teaching you it's that
that person on Tik Tock who does funny
dances it's teaching it's like we're
taught the entire generation of kids
coming up to be quite vacuous because
that's what we've given them we've given
them a quite a quite a an empty culture
which is funny and you know great for
passing attention in every 10 seconds
but it's like we're like if we're not
careful we'll create a generation of
epsilons where they're just never
thinking a long thought never thinking a
deep thought it's just go go go next
thought you know nothing wrong with
their brains and when you I find and
that's one thing if if a parent was
saying well what do I do and so one
thing I said well don't maybe if not
don't go to a therapist maybe figure out
yourself what's going down and get in
there but another thing I would argue
that parents should do is go in with
depth this idea of keeping things light
because it'll be heavy that's not what
teenagers want teenagers want dep they
want kind of why why why haven't we
figured out homelessness why is there
starving people in different countries
do you follow mean so going in with
depth is much more nourishing than
maintaining this silly
vacuous P that Society is teaching us to
kind of maintain and it's also as well
that I feel that more and more and and I
saw it when I was a drama teacher
actually it seems that every year the
kids got a little bit worse at relating
to one another cuz a lot of drama is you
know you create long form improvisations
and devised improvisation and devised
improvisation is where people create a
play and it doesn't have a script but
they create it and then they perform it
and it just seemed more and more that
the kids were losing the capacity to
listen and share ideas and not only only
that they've lost the capacity cuz they
they've measured this to kind of rough
play has really gone to Pieces cuz
they're hitting each other too hard CU
they've no ability to hit each other
lightly because do you follow me their
actual physical interaction skills
haven't been nurtured in the way they
would have been in other Generations
because they had screens instead so you
know the way you have to practice a lot
of times before you get it right so when
you're two and three and stuff you're
practicing well they didn't get to
practice and so yeah they they they're
their ability to interact has been
walloped by social media and it's
happening all over the place where you
can see it and I you know it's it's
amazing because it was happening and
everybody was talking about it and I was
writing about it you were talking about
oh everybody was and then Co happened
and it
just it you know multiplied by by a
magnitude during Co and so those kids
are literally coming out every teacher
cuz I often talk to you know teachers
because of working a lot with teenagers
and they're all saying these Co kids
like there's a significant issue because
they've been on screen so much their
their ability to handle social life is
really reduced so a lot of the teenagers
I'd be working with so they were very
lonely during Co and loneliness is is
awful and then they were very reluctant
to become back friends after covid they
were anxious because you know the world
had made them frightened of of disease
that doesn't affect them but we're never
going to die for let's park that they
were anxious for that reason and so
they'd be very very very off and telling
me how they're messaging their mates and
I'm like isn't your mate like doesn't
doesn't she live 200 yards from you and
they're like ah yeah but we prefer
messaging or like another kid and every
time he called over to his friend his
friend would send him back home saying
let's just talk on Xbox like you go home
and I yeah I in I'm going on Xbox you're
going on XB we can talk or whatever it
was PS4 whatever um because not
massively comfortable being in each
other's company much happier still
wanted to hang out with them but you go
back to your house and I'll talk to you
on on Xbox this is really common this
and this kind of late night text and so
they're they're kind of very vacuous
very vain very funny and silly arguably
in school then real life comes in cuz
you're on your own and bedroom and stuff
like that and they're sending really
quite dark messages to each other late
at night which will be filled with real
kind of Revelations about their self
harming or their eating disorder or some
really quite awful distressing things
and um it'll be done by text which is
not the same as if I spoke to you or if
I spoke to you and we had a real heart
heart there's a feeling of nourishment
or something now if it goes bad it's
awful and it's very vulnerable making
and you feel very alienated if it goes
well you feel really like we've deepened
our relationship and it's actually very
hard to describe how much of an impact
that makes these kids aren't doing any
of that there's none of that it's not
obviously I'm generalizing wildly but
just to make the point because it's
notable among the different um age
groups is they're messaging each other
so I'm hurting myself and all that the
kid might write back oh that's awful
that sort of thing is happening then the
next day go hi and it's back to Bakery
and then that nice dark messaging again
that's not that's that wouldn't have
happened in any other generation so in
in terms of social media and all the
rest of it then is I mean do your kids
have smartphones they do they they do
would would well I mean yeah I'm all
over them if that's what you're asking
well I guess the question really is is
should kids have smartphones I don't
yeah I think you know I think they
shouldn't have them as long as possible
I think as we get get older I imagine by
the time your kid has grown up it won't
be so ubiquitous by the time they're 13
I was very resistant to them getting
them and when they got them they got
crappy ones that didn't quite work and
were old phones of ours that just press
lots of times and kept on going out of
battery so they kind of got a very
stilted introduction to it and I'm all
over them like get them out of the
bedrooms and you know what I mean have
them plugged in outside my room at night
and stuff like that but yeah I I I think
trying to raise a kid without smartphone
a teenager without a smartphone it's
such
aulan task that I wish you well if you
do it but I I think it's really hard
these days I think you'd be better off
just like learning everything difficult
in life you'd be better off learning
teaching them how to handle themselves
how to put it away it's like junk food
and it's like alcohol when you're older
do you know what I mean youve got to
learn how to deal with this do you know
what I mean yes but we know with both of
those things there are some people who
are not capable of dealing with it
properly without really like you know
totally and I think this the same with
smartphones well well no doubt I mean
there will be people whose whose brains
are literally broken by the thing for
sure and by the way I say people there
are
times I found when I had covid it I I
had it three times it made me incredibly
angry I was constantly very angry all
the time which is the natural go-to
place for me when things aren't the way
that I want it's my natural response
which I generally keep really under
control most of the time but when I had
covid I was really angry and I was a
prick to everyone on social media right
so I'm thinking what if I was 13 my
brain's completely unregulated I haven't
had 40 Years of trying to work out who I
am what I'm supposed to do with myself
Etc so I
just that that I think is the real and
you say we may not be as ubiquitous I
wonder what the future of that is
because I don't think parents giving
their the children and unfettered access
to the internet is is is working out no
I don't think it's working out I think
even 10 years from now I think there'll
be more knowledge not to to have
controls for example when I was first
started talking so my first book came
out in 2015 and I was all over social
media saying parental controls and all
this massive resistance from parents now
they're like it's accepted that there
should be parental control so I've I've
seen that happen in8 years the just a a
kind of accept
that either you should be controlling it
or you're guiltily not controlling it
you know which brings us in terms of
people's opinions of something changing
over time very nicely onto the biggest
issue that anybody ever talks about on
the internet nowadays which is of course
trans how does trans play into all of
this massively massively tell us more um
you know like it's amazing like that
first book I wrote was cotton w kids and
it was about how these kind of overp
parented kids weren't turning out very
well they were becoming very anxious
they were on the internet too much they
were online too much and then I never
knew obviously this is 2015 I had no
idea that this this bomb was going to
explode in my life a few years later and
um when it did I thought they're the
kids I've always been talking about
they're the same kids clever cerebral
overp parented kids who who aren't out
enough who aren't outside playing who
who are kind of inside and very very
impressive with their extracurricular
activities their music and their you
know whatever their dance or whatever
and also their academics and it's on
paper they're very impressive and then
they go online too much and they get
sucked into something because they're
looking for depth and meaning because
that's the noble and natural aspiration
for any teenager and when you're looking
for depth and meaning and you're 14
today and you're kind of thinking the
very very normal question healthily
appropriate which is who am I what am I
for who am I I don't fit in that's what
you should be thinking when you're that
age they will find very quickly who am I
will lead to well you might be trans I
know that sounds a leap but if people
Google it as if you're a teenager you'll
see the jumps go quite fast queer Theory
and that
entire kind of um movement is off
teenagers what every every era of
teenagers have saw which is a kind of
sticking it to the man it's you know tur
it it upside down it's rejecting your
parents values do you follow me it's
it's doing all the things that teenage
culture has been doing since arguably
the 50s do you know what I mean and it
is got an added Spectre of
medicalization that you know other other
Generations you know the 60s they had
loads of drugs and that didn't go so
well you know what I mean Punk whatever
but this one the medicalization of
children just feels really grim and I
had my own experience as a kid I had
when I was about three like as far back
as I go when I was a kid I was uh I was
I wanted to be a boy and it lasted many
years and it was horrible feeling wasn't
nice and it was very deep and it was
very
ingrained and um I was a strange kid I
was an unhappy kid but it was a strange
kid and I I wanted to be a boy and I was
very good at being a boy I could beat up
all the boys and played and I still see
that boyishness in me you know what I
mean it it doesn't stun me I think I
would have been a great boy I could have
been great um but yeah I obviously
wasn't a boy and puberty so many years
later puberty was very Grim for me it
was awful it was like oh my God like
just to go to the toilet think of what's
going to happen next like it was it was
awful it was it's a very good way of
describing it it was a terrible terrible
time I was lonely and devastated and all
over the place but
ultimately long story short I pulled out
of it and I'm glad I'm a woman and
actually the most important thing to me
is the fact that I became a mother I
love being a mother bad as I am but no I
love being a mother and it's so so much
such a part of me and I I kind of in the
midst of all my mental health world I
really realize what are they doing with
kids kids like me kids who had the
experience that I had and they're
medicalizing them so that they'll be one
day infertile and a different sex and
have impaired sexual functioning I was
horrified when I realized kids like me
were being medicalized of course
obviously it's completely imposing my
own experience on these kids and yet
there's validity with it I did have that
experience I had it for years and
arguably
sometimes experience does count for
something and as well as that as
obviously I have expertise in mental
health to put the two together I started
talking about it and it's been insane
ever since the thing that always gets me
is that they talk about this as if it's
one particular issue and you go this is
several issues that we're talking about
here the fact that you
know it just seems that more and more
and more goes are transitioning 42% of
them was a statistic that I saw recently
were autistic that's very different to
the boys that's very different to men
transitioning when they're older why do
can we not have a conversation where we
look at all of these things individually
as opposed to lumping them all together
Under the Umbrella of trans stop being
transphobic mate yeah yeah what's
this um I suppose we're living in in a
sound by culture that wants the quick
solution very you know what what's the
headline on that Francis is what they're
saying do you know what I mean give it
to me in for words well I just did stop
being trans yeah well done yeah exactly
so I suppose because people aren't
seeking the longwinded explanation
people aren't interested but you're
right like you know never before there
was always a cohort of very young
children I'm actually classic my
experience is very typical there was a
small number of very young children who
are extremely strange and generally
about 70% of those kids ended up being
gay lesbian or or bisexual and some of
them like myself weren't but it that
that's kind of irrelevant as in they
were always there and then there was
always a group of middle-aged men who
sought medical transition certainly in
in the last 100 years again a very small
number and then suddenly out of nowhere
the teenagers who had never before been
seen in the literature vanishingly rare
no kind of no studies on them because
nobody ever saw teenager seeking medical
transition and they arrived and when you
look at the graphs of social media and
when you look at the graphs of um
smartphone use from around 2012 it
shoots up social media shoots up and
gender issues shoot up and if you if you
do a graph on it you think it's
incredibly similar as arcs and yeah it
does seem to be very much supported
online and at a certain time type of kid
and um that kid is very often like you
say neurodiverse very often autistic
ADHD little bit isolated a little bit
lonely often after a traumatic incident
and what do they do do you remember back
in the day if you were lonely and you
were you know you you'd had some trauma
as you often do in adolescence you went
into your bedroom and in my area you
listen to music and you I got it changed
my life to be honest as a teenager where
they go is the internet social media
that's where they go and that's where
they find it and there's a perfect storm
which is extraordinary to study of
everything that's going on that lands
them into queer Theory and they might be
trans it's weird when you see it because
you're like how's this happened but when
you actually UNP pick it you can see
exactly what's happened it's such a
profound point because when I remember
when I was growing up you know you talk
about a kid who was neuro diverse and a
little bit you know I had a lot of
friends but very sensitive blah blah
blah I mean you got into music I listen
to you know the bands of my generation
like Nirvana talking about you know
teenage angs not fitting in not being
part of the world wanting to withdraw
you know there's also the element of
putting two fingers up to the
world I don't see that in kids now those
kind of Pop Culture bands which had had
and garnered huge followings they don't
really seem to exist anymore I remember
the first teenager I had working with
counseling not she wasn't the first one
that I ever had but the first when he
said no I just I don't like music I was
like you don't like music how can you
don't like music it's just like just
doesn't doesn't do it for me L the vast
majority of them music is just something
in the background it's just not that big
now there will be of course there'll be
exceptions and people will write in and
say my kid is mad into music but mostly
no music is not that heartbeat of
teenage hood that it was for us wow I
know they're missing a lot because it's
kind of transcendental it lifts you into
a kind of universality when I realized
when I listen to the lyrics and yeah it
was so profound for me and for so many
others they don't have it you know it's
interesting I actually am not that into
music now but but but now that you are
talking about it I remember as you were
talking about when I was a teenager I
used to listen to music all the time
yeah and it did help me dealing with all
sorts of you know emotions and whatever
so we're running out of time we're going
to go to locals in a second second where
our audience are going to ask you their
questions and we'll continue the
conversation with some of our own um but
before we go to our last question just
very quickly give us a kind of like
toolkit or some kind of practical ideas
for parents and if there are teenagers
listening you know how do you deal with
some of the stuff all of the stuff that
we've talked about what are some of the
things to just to focus on to think
about to maybe do when you when you are
in a difficult place just a little two
minutes on on what people can and should
do if you're worried about your kid yeah
if you're worried about your kid there
is a there is a way you can go at it
okay and you know first of all in a way
you have to kind of think I'm going in
and there's a kind of a level of
confidence needed cuz you know you you
ask the kid what's going on and you very
much zip at yourself you don't give
Hollywood coach kind of with a towel
around your neck kind of inspiring
speeches instead you ask them to clarify
what's going on cuz often you'll think
it's a and it'll actually be B so it
might look like it's their friends but
it's something else that's going on so
you ask over a period of time you don't
jump in like you're grueling them but
you ask them questions to clarify and
when you've clarified and any good
therapist would know this when you've
clarified you check that you've got it
right and you say am I writing think and
say I'm I'm trying to help you and I I
might have it right but I'm I right in
thinking that what's really upsetting
you is the fact that you're not doing as
well as your other friends in school and
it's making you feel stupid is that what
it is and be very open to rolled eyes
and no that's not it and it's cool it's
fine cuz when somebody is doesn't
understand you and you're upset it's
very upset and you can be very the kid
can be very harsh about that Let It Go
just just keep plowing on because you've
committed to the fact that you want to
help them when you've actually when they
actually say yeah that's what it is
you'll usually see a physical kind of a
sigh a shoulders a kind of yeah you know
what I mean and that's a real crucial
point because so many of us as parents
we're terrified of our of our kids pain
we're terrified of their distress we
want to think it's just little kids
little problems and so we think oh
you'll be all right or just it'll be
better and instead have the courage to
have the empathy to kind of get into the
trenches with them say ah now I get it
now I get it that takes a kind of
emotional bravery and then when you've
gone in there of I get it then try not
to jump in with massive solution very
quickly because that diminishes it and
it's more along communicating solidarity
of okay I can see this is a big problem
I get it and we're not going to fix this
today or tomorrow like I will look up
things and I'll look for Solutions but
you're kind of shown a a a seriousness
to it so let me let me help you work
with work with you on this and it could
take us ages and we could take loads of
wrong turns but just know I've got your
back I'm on your team shoulder to-
shoulder just let's give some time to
this so if you can just do that if you
can kind of clarify what it is have some
empathy and then kind of say we'll give
it some time let's try lots of things
that's an amazing feeling it's an
amazing feeling for anybody to think
they get it and they know it's not a
easily fixed and they're willing to try
it in the long term now that I've said
that very fast but honestly if you took
your time with that and that could take
a couple of months to do it would be
worth its Wai and goal for any kid
that's really good advice because I
think we do live in the kind of quick
fix Hollywood speech kind of environment
uh they don't work it doesn't work
unfortunately sorry Sylvester Stallone
um so before we go to locals our last
question in this part of the interview
is always the same which is what's the
one thing we're not talking about as a
society that you think we really should
be I think what we're not talking about
is that there is a a a a a a kind of a
really thick online culture of Reddit
and you know different social media
where they're all affirming each other
in a very female empathetic way and it's
making people feel worse and worse and
worse so it's kind of toxic empathy
where everybody's oh it's really hard
for you oh it's really hard for you and
nobody is willing to do the hard kind of
the hard challenging conversation with
people you should see my Twitter feed
yeah yeah Twitter is its own crazy world
which I enjoy I'm kidding yeah but the
I'm talking about the teenage world
where everybody is so empathe atic and
kind to each other and it's all oh don't
worry don't worry and it's it's very un
nourishing because nobody will give it
to you straight truth has a value yeah
and depth has a value and it's vacuous
and I think it's I think there's a a
real
genuine toxic culture I know everybody
says it but I think we're not talking
about just how toxic it is to be a
teenager these days I think it's I think
it's really hard and I think they're
suffering on a on a deep level
and I I think it's it's really
unfortunate because we've never had it
so good Stella M thank you so much head
on over to locals where we continue the
conversation my daughter's currently 6
years old how will I keep her respect
and Trust if stroke when her or her
friend's views and desires conflict with
[Music]
mine